[Music]
hey guys happy sunday holy [ __ ] what the
hell is that noise
why are you doing that
what's up
how's everybody's weekend going
ah
so
we're gonna talk about what are you
doing over there i'm uh adjusting my uh
video quality just save on data oh okay
yeah so we got like a couple uh brittany
says long time lurker first time poster
hey there
what's going on
uh gadget three hey everyone been a
while yes indeed it has
yeah so we did avp a couple days ago
and uh i'd seen what requiem i wanted to
do that one so that's what's on the list
for today
alien versus predator requiem it's part
two of the alien versus predator
little series which this which this was
the last one it was his last one yeah i
mean you know i don't think they had
another one after this no they actually
they plan to but
they didn't do another one even though i
mean this made
decent money i think it cost 40 million
to make and it made 130 million yeah
which is usually real low budget
for 10. that's nothing yeah
yeah for a movie of this uh kind it is
it is very low budget so
you know i remember when it came out
man's movie was getting a lot of hate
it still does yeah i mean this seems
pretty
largely reviled
and i kind of feel like unfairly it's
not a fantastic movie and i did have
like a lot of issues with it
but if we're gonna be
i mean honestly i liked it a little bit
better than the first one oh yeah i did
yeah because it was like at least the
first one was kind of a little bit like
boring in parts and commercial
yeah and i kind of feel like the
characters weren't maybe weren't as
interesting in the first one whereas in
this one i liked it better because it
was more i guess
grounded in reality like it was like
aliens and predators
and predaliens like invade
a regular town
yeah like a small town and i kind of
liked that angle you know what's weird
is that i could have sworn that i had
not seen this movie
and then we started watching it and we
got to the part with uh you know the guy
getting out of jail and then the pizza
guy getting his ass kicked at his
girlfriend's house or his uh his crush's
house rather and i'm sitting there going
i saw this [ __ ] movie how did i see
this [ __ ] movie i didn't go to the
theater and see it and then i was like
you know casting back my head because
this came back out in 2007 and i was
like oh i bet what happened was that a
long time ago i used to work at the
daytona beach news journal and i used to
work the night shift like in the graphic
design department and i had a friend in
the department named al and he would
like rent every single movie ever that
came out and then he would make a copy
of it so he usually loaned me so i got
to see all kind of movies for free and
this must have been one of the ones that
he loaned me because
i was like yeah i've seen this before
it's like really familiar but i
completely forgot that i saw it so
i think it's a good movie
um it does have problems
and i'm gonna agree with uh
most of the hate that it got is that uh
certain action sequences are very dark
oh yeah obviously big time i'll agree
with that
uh you can't see and it's also the edit
the edit is very very fast
uh and
because it's so dark you can't tell what
happened like what came from where and
who got who like there's one scene where
uh the predator or yeah he's kind of
like the predator game warden he's down
in the sewers fighting fighting these uh
aliens the xenomorphs
and he sets up these traps that have
laser beams
and the aliens are running at him and i
guess they can't see the laser beams you
know their vision is a lot different
than ours and one alien one one alien
runs right through them is just cut to
pieces but the other ones see that
and somehow get around it and come from
behind and and
they
they suggest what happens
but the edit is so fast and the shot is
so dark you can't see
how those
xenomorphs got around that
that uh trap or that it's like a net of
[ __ ] projected laser beams
i think i think there was another tunnel
or something that it went around them
but you really couldn't tell
i i couldn't tell you i just i didn't
see it either and then certain things
happen and it happens in darkness and
you can't really tell what it was or try
to show you
now it was even worse
on some of the old televisions that i
first saw this on
but
on this version and this is the unrated
version that we saw
on a hd television
uh
it's not 4k but it's high definition
you can see a lot better
which tells me that in theater
you probably had a better view of what
had happened
i doubt it though because i do kind of
feel like that was one of the main
criticisms from critics that saw it in
the theater were like you can't see what
the [ __ ] is going on it's too dark so i
don't even think it was
and the scenes were just [ __ ] dark
man yeah i couldn't tell
who i was like who just got killed who
was that what's going on in the old
on old televisions it would have been
much worse though well yeah it would
have just been they might as well just
put scene missing yeah like uh now uh
what they tried to do with this is they
tried to basically
bring the the dog i liked the dark idea
what they were trying to do is they were
trying to bring the darkness of like
alien one yeah to you yeah i get that
they were trying that's what they were
trying to do and then they were trying
to have
human military stuff
inside
fights with aliens and [ __ ] predators
they were trying to bring kind of like
alien to or aliens
that experience to it and really i think
if you watched aliens or alien 2
the edits were also very fast it was
almost subliminal
uh
and a lot of the stuff was dark it's
just that it was a lot
the edit was a lot better in aliens or
alien too
yeah the edit was fast
and it was kind of dark but you could
tell what was going on um
if you were to take this movie go in
there and
maybe add
just a few more frames into each one of
those little uh action scenes
and lighten it digitally a little bit so
you could see what had happened
this would be a totally different movie
it probably would because i do kind of
feel like i don't really have an issue i
wanted to say oh thank you gadgey3 got a
super chat weekend is okay got the
plague oh [ __ ] gonna drink my way
through it yeah that's the best way to
to get through that stuff but yeah it's
like overall i don't really think there
was that much wrong with the story like
i said i was kind of interested i
thought the characters in this and
because it was set on earth and it was
set i mean the first one was on earth
too but the first one was set like in a
more remote
kind of location yeah so it was more
like uh you know one
one level removed from like normal life
so i kind of liked you know the aliens
and the predators uh like invading a
regular town i like that they made this
one r rated uh the first one the
theatrical cut was pg-13 although we
watched the unrated one it really didn't
seem to need it but yeah this one has a
lot more gore but again you can't really
see it because it's too dark
uh i will say that i did like the
ballsiness of killing the kids the kid
first uh that was that was pretty
awesome like pretty early in the movie
i'm like oh they went there nice i
killed the kid and the kid got pregnant
by the damn alien and it popped out of
his chest and everything i was like yeah
yeah i mean the alien doesn't care if
he's a kid or anything he's like dad dad
he sees his dad the damn facehugger
look at this right gotcha [ __ ]
this is aliens okay this is aliens we
don't care that you're a kid you're
gonna die
i like that part it was great i did too
because i was just kind of i didn't know
if they would but i was just kind of
like now they better not let the kid
like skate his way out of this and i was
like oh they didn't all right i see what
you did to their movie i like that yeah
and also and this is kind of like a
spoiler alert but i feel like a lot of
people have seen this honestly this
movie killed uh pretty much everybody
yeah yeah
at the end it ended with a [ __ ]
nuclear
uh a nuclear bomb blast that yeah
but it's the only way to be sure is it
yeah it was outbreak of [ __ ] toxic
aliens
and uh the humans wiped them out
and uh then the corporations got a hold
of them predator technology
it's i thought it was a good idea here
here's the premise if you guys saw the
first avp
the predator at the end that makes it to
the end got pregnant by the alien and
what pops out at the end of that movie
is a [ __ ] alien with the jaws like a
predator it's a predalian
so
a little scout ship comes in this one
it continues that story little scout
ship comes out goes back to the [ __ ]
planet earth um
it gets it uh the pilots the the
predator pilots get attacked by the dow
predator by the predalien
um one predator gets killed another
predator shoots at the predator blows
the [ __ ] hole out of sight of his own
ship the ship crashes on earth
some hunters see it there's a guy with
his young this boy
a little kid he's probably about ten
eight to ten they see the ship crash
they go and find it they find the aliens
and then they get impregnated they get
raped by the damn
xenomorphs now there's an alien outbreak
the last um
uh that last predator somehow i think he
was
tried to blow himself up but he didn't
he he didn't have time
and i think he i think a distress call
got sent back to the damn predator plant
yeah i think though and they had a dude
on duty here who heard it
and he answers the call to try to see
what the problem was and he's basically
if you know anything about you know
american a lot of this is based on
american hunting laws and hunting
traditions that we have here it's the
game warden okay game warden goes down
the predator game warden he goes down
there to see what the problem was he
investigates gets dna and finds out
there was not only was an alien outbreak
it's a predalien and he's like oh [ __ ]
and he sees it through the helmet of the
other predator the predator that got
killed because it was recorded
well because it's an honor-based hunting
society does he call for help [ __ ] no
[ __ ] gonna [ __ ] solve this on his
own he's gonna solve it on his own okay
he takes his mask off he's all battle
scarred half his face is gone already so
he's been through all kinds of [ __ ] he
doesn't have just one gun he's got two
and then he's got a whole bunch of other
stuff a damn alien sawed-off shotgun
he's got all kinds of [ __ ] spears
throwing stars [ __ ] minds that shoot
lasers
so he's he's a bad boy okay he's going
to handle this outbreak on his own all
right which i like that part yeah [ __ ]
calling for help i'm going to take care
of this
so he's tr and that's just where the fun
begins this predalien
it's half predator half alien
has a strange abilities
it can impregnate pregnant women
think of that yeah that was actually a
cool scene too i kind of liked that
it's it
it may it had some eggs they had some
eggs in the ship and they got onto some
people and what came out of them looked
a little different than a normal
predator and i i don't remember it's
that i had to go back and watch they may
have been created in a slightly
different way
um
but
the predalien ends up in in its it
travels
going into a damn hospital
all right
actually it made a predator i think out
of another it made some predator it made
some aliens out of a woman in the in the
diner didn't it
it well it just impregnated her right i
mean he did yeah i didn't see i didn't
remember what busted out of her though
what was her name carrie or something
like that she's like the waitress right
i think he got it out of the way he now
she was the wife or girlfriend of the
first cop that got killed right that cop
that got killed out in the woods i can't
keep when they were looking for the
hunter
oh and that the he had that acid too
that bright blue acid that like
dissolved everything that was super cool
yeah because he's the game warden and he
has investigative powers and i guess law
enforcement powers because if you if you
know american laws in most of the states
like especially the south
[ __ ] game wardens have more power
than a damn federal agent they can come
into your house without any warrants and
look in your refrigerator and see if
you've been poaching to see what kind of
meat you got in there if you're a
suspected poacher they usually don't do
it and if you were guilty of anything
else i don't think they could use it
against you
but
they have they have power to go and go
into your house and [ __ ] see if
you're a poacher and they have the power
to do their own investigations on you
so
it's usually state state powers so
anyway uh this pres this this predator
is kind of like that he's doing uh he's
got investigated technology you know
tracking people's set based on their
damn dna profiles he's got all he's got
this stuff to hide evidence
it's this [ __ ] blue fluid and it's
it's not acid it's something better than
that
he just would could pour it on something
and it would just start dissolving that
[ __ ] it would even go up and dissolve
things it's like it was some kind of a
molecular disassembly fluid
and it would just vanish nothing would
be left maybe that sounds like an indie
band molecule
that's or like a new retro wave channel
right like a vapor wave or something oh
we got another super chat from gadget3
again thank you very much do me a favor
and tell donna she is beautiful you're
beautiful donna you are beautiful
beautiful don't you ever forget it take
it off donna
i'm like no but well now
that's it i don't know who donna
donna might be eight i don't know
donna might be eight yeah yeah that
would be [ __ ] up that's what i mean
maybe you shouldn't say that i just
can't get in trouble it's part of my job
to talk [ __ ]
so anyway
so he's got the molecular disassembly
fluid and he does all kinds of [ __ ] real
cool [ __ ] with that uh
and he's making
any signs of the damn xenomorphs or or
any alien creatures or anything he's
causing them to disappear
so the human authorities don't see him i
can't find it there's no evidence for
anything
which uh that's pretty slick um
[ __ ] i forgot i was what i was gonna oh
anyway what i was talking about is what
the predalien ends up doing in one scene
he goes to the hospital and he's looking
around
and he sees the maternity ward and he's
like uh-huh this is what i've been
looking for
and he's grabbing [ __ ] pregnant women
while they're
getting ready to give birth and
something comes out of its mouth and
encapsulates their mouth and you can see
it pumping eggs eggs about the size of a
damn
orange down into their throats and goes
in their bellies and turn them into a
down breeding pod and the other women
are seeing that predator and [ __ ]
he's like i'm coming for you too well
anyway he turns them all into down
breeding pods
and when they uh they all [ __ ] pop
pop pop and they come out there like
seven or eight of them per woman come
out
so i really like that part of it that
this thing has the ability to just
reproduce
without any it i it's like a predalien
queen that'd be like yeah
but you know one hosting you'll get
seven or eight of them and when they
come out they kind of look
deformed they don't really look normal
their faces are kind of
wrong
so it's not a normal xenomorph that
comes out like a xenomorph
clone kind of like something from the
brood
yeah remember that remember that
the movie the broods like that
but uh
then the army gets involved
uh
army gets its ass kicked and there's
some scenes that are kind of like out of
kind of like got a alien too
i mean i kind of liked how the i mean
the
you know the the predaliens everything
is just kind of like they're all running
amok and then also aliens and predators
and it's just kind of like run all over
this town which is gunness in colorado
by the way yeah and uh so if everybody's
getting killed as they would
and i like that they're like well now
we're gonna wait for the national guard
or the army or whatever to show up and
it's like they show up and literally
like two minutes later they all get
[ __ ] wiped out yeah and then they
were just like well [ __ ] now what do we
do yeah
what's cool about the the predator game
warden is that he's trying to stop the
outbreak
but he's also hunting at the same time
yeah well you might as well two kill two
birds
while you're there some crazy
[ __ ] out there with this gun
telling the the women of the children
shut up did you i saw one
shut up he's telling him to shut up and
little girl's like whoa you know
and uh his head popped up like that boom
blew his head off in front of the front
of the little child and the woman and
she almost went to go grab for the gun
and she goes nah because the damn laser
beams came
and said maybe i shouldn't grab that she
just ran off and he's like yeah [ __ ] you
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] off over here get
out of here
and uh
yeah
like i said had they just cleaned up
a couple of those action scenes made it
just a shade or two lighter so you can
see a little bit better and added a
couple of frames
and you know not a lot just let it at
the same leave it at the same level like
predator 2. that should be alien too but
some of that stuff is almost subliminal
but this is just too damn extreme
this movie i think would have been a
totally different movie
because it's a good story i mean yeah i
do kind of feel like you know there were
some uh criticisms of like oh the
characters weren't interesting or blah
blah blah i didn't really find that it
does have a lot of characters because
it's you know it's a small town and
they're all kind of like interrelated
and so a lot of them don't get a lot of
screen time but i didn't really have a
problem none of the characters were
annoying or anything like that um and i
kind of like
you know you you got a flavor like an
idea of this kind of small town and then
like all these aliens invade and i kind
of liked that too i liked how
sort of brutal it was like i said as far
as killing kids but essentially they
killed pretty much everybody yeah now uh
somebody said didn't they didn't the
crush get killed like the girl yeah she
got killed
at the swimming pool i think that was
around that area maybe maybe after so
there's this good scene where the the
teenagers go back to the swimming pool
play some grab ass
and then the uh the bullies show up to
beat his ass for stealing the woman
and uh the alien the xenomorphs get into
the damn pool and eat a bunch of them
and uh eventually the predator predator
game warden shows up sees them down in
the pool and pours some of that damn
blue fluid that rapidly evaporates and
just de-molecularized the damn pool
water and everything that is in it that
was cool as [ __ ] i don't even think
there was any steam was there
oh no though there might have been nice
i can't even remember everything else
was gone
it wasn't it wasn't a whole swimming
pool
uh it wasn't a whole swimming pool worth
of steam
a swimming pool where the steam would be
a cloud well because when the cops came
later the swimming pool was empty
totally empty yeah i thought anybody in
there like i said it was kind of it's
kind of dark so it's hard to tell yeah
you know what i mean everything's very
very different [ __ ]
i need some of that blue [ __ ] don't we
all yeah i could throw that on
somebody's car
while they're driving
[Laughter]
too much traffic today
yeah well knowing my dumb ass i'd
probably just like spill it on myself
yeah
and then i'm like ah there's my feet
going yeah that was kind of that was
kind of strange he's standing there and
just pouring a little bit of it on the
damn
his face hugger at his feet and a lot
like he's not even worried about getting
that on him
maybe it doesn't work on him i don't
know maybe it's some kind of like weird
dna kind of [ __ ] they're like well maybe
it's yeah it's like nanites
yeah maybe that's what it knows
it's got like a target list because i
mean there can't be there had to be at
least one time when some like trainee
predator was kind of like doing it and
there was like ah yeah
and that's how dangerous
how dangerous it would be to make that
right that's what i'm saying yeah so you
know i mean it's cool [ __ ] but yeah i
don't know if i'd want it well honestly
and they kind of use a little bit of
because the xenomorphs have like acid
blood right yeah and i kind of feel like
sometimes the movies remember that and
sometimes the movies forget that this
one remembers it for the most part
what they forget is the strength of the
acid the acid sometimes is weaker than
it is than it was in the original movie
because in the original movie it went
like all the way through like all the
[ __ ] and it was gonna go down and
like make like pierce the hull you know
yeah
so
but uh not a perfect movie uh but the
things that are wrong with it are
forgivable
uh by today's standards this is a great
movie i couldn't uh the standards used
to be higher i think
um when this movie came out but compared
to a lot of [ __ ] they make today
this is a [ __ ] masterpiece
you say that about everything well it
depends on i'm taking time into an
account he's trying to undermine what
i'm saying this is better than the
predator
i like it better than the predator uh
like i said i think if if
some of the issues with this were fixed
i didn't have an issue with characters i
didn't have an issue with the story it's
actually like a decent idea for a story
i just didn't like
the editing and i didn't like that it
was so goddamn dark yeah and so most of
the time it was just really confusing
because i'm like what the [ __ ] is going
on like who was that like who is
fighting now
is that the print alien is this who is
this you could probably get away with
the edit if you touched it up and made a
little bit lighter yeah those deeds that
might have been
i mean i think that was really the main
problem it was just like really really
confusing now the first movie
which was kind of dark too but you could
usually see more of what was going on
the first movie i kind of had problems
with the edit not so much that the edit
was fast which it was but that the edits
were too close up during the fight
scenes yeah so i couldn't really i know
why they do that
but
uh so again i couldn't really tell what
was going on particularly just in the
fight scenes this one
kind of took that and
took that problem and like ramped it up
and also turned all the lights off so i
couldn't like tell what was going on
thank you no need for me too glad i'm
free lots of problems solved oh that's
awesome pushing through the rest thanks
for the distraction well you're welcome
um
yeah tommy beat me too it said it's
better than the last reboot attempt yeah
yeah i honestly didn't mind this movie
at all um you know it does seem to get a
lot of hate
but
it's really not that bad if it was like
lightened up and honestly i will say too
like the guys that directed it the
brothers strauss uh colin and greg
they actually this is the first movie
they directed they're actually like
special effects guys uh they had a
special effects
company uh so they had worked on [ __ ]
i think they worked on the x-files and
they worked on movies like volcano and
300 and stuff like that and uh they had
wanted to
make an alien vs predator movie and i
think that they had done like an idea
for it and it got rejected but then this
one came along so
they did actually
most of the effects in this are
practical they said they did use cgi for
exterior spaceships obviously um and
then some of the stuff like the little
you know the little alien inside the
alien mouth and like some of their tails
whipping around they said we used cgi
for that but most of the big monsters
and everything like were puppets and
stuff like that so solid man yeah so
they did actually use mostly practical
effects not as much as the older ones
but they just minor minor cgi avp1 the
visual tone is kind of like predator 2
where it kind of had a little bit
brighter colors even though it is dark
but it had a little bit brighter tones
it's like
black and blue that's kind of the tone
for avp1
when predator 2 was kind of like red and
black that's kind of the feeling i had
lots of reds lots of blacks
um but just the way that it felt
avp1 kind of felt
edit wise and just tonally kind of like
predator 2.
requiem or avp2
for me
tonally felt
more like alien two
alien two and alien one that's what
they're trying to go for tonally
and like i'm said if it was just a
little bit lighter
and i'm not even talking about i'm
talking about a total of like [ __ ]
three
seconds no probably like
six seconds of film
total in total of the movie yeah because
it's so fast it probably only adds up to
like maybe six seven seconds yeah
probably because it's not long if that
six or seven seconds not many frames if
it was maybe two shades lighter
this movie would have been i think as
good as predator two excuse me as good
as alien two and that's saying a lot
it's real close to that
it's real close to it it's just
now you know
the story is similar
i think the uh special effects were
similar the tone was kind of similar
it's just you couldn't see some of the
action
yeah and that kind of sucked because i
mean i felt like it was good actually
that there was cool [ __ ] going on and
there was some gore but it seemed like
it was all just mostly like a suggestion
yeah because you couldn't really see it
all the time i don't know if they were
trying to hide
effects that weren't that good quality i
mean like i said this movie only cost 40
million they didn't give them a lot of
money because i guess they were special
effects guys and this was their first
directing job so maybe i think it's 20th
century fox so maybe they were just kind
of like well we'll just give you 40
million don't [ __ ] it up yeah um
so
it didn't strike me like when i was
watching the movie it didn't strike me
as oh this is a low-budget movie no like
it doesn't look like a low-budget movie
it looks great but knowing that it only
cost only 40 million i wish somebody
would give me only 40 million dollars um
but yeah that's nothing in that world
yeah in that world in the and
particularly for this type of sci-fi
movie that is
yeah that's like that's like not that
budget so um so the fact that they were
able to do that it's like really
impressive but like you said it might
have just been they were trying to make
it dark
maybe because they were trying to evoke
the first alien but also maybe because
well the darker we make it like you
won't be able to see if some of the
effects aren't good good although as far
as i know like their effects company
they're actually like pretty well
regarded like prior to this so it's not
like they were known for doing shitty
work or anything well i liked the dark
idea yeah it's just that it was executed
a little bit too dark it needed to be a
shade or two a little bit lighter so you
could make out what was on the frames
you just suggested you could kinda
but not really um
it would probably take multiple viewings
to understand everything that happens
and you might have to [ __ ] watch it
in slow motion
the the uh
the action scenes i wonder if you can i
wonder if we could like take our tv and
like bump up the brightness like quite a
bit this could be fixed this movie could
easily be fixed yeah easily and it's
only a few seconds and it would be a
totally different movie
yeah i mean for people that didn't like
it because they thought the characters
were boring or something like that well
you know i can't help you with that but
honestly i don't think the characters
were boring i didn't think they were
either i mean i like i said i thought
the characters in this were more
interesting than the characters in the
first one i think so too they're more
realistic characters yeah because like i
said i guess i liked that better yeah uh
you know than
the characters and the other which were
all kind of like professionals you know
what i mean i guess and i kind of like
this one because it was just kind of
like a teenager like you know an army
mom and her daughter and just regular
asp and like a waitress and like normal
ass people so i liked that better and
then and then i liked too that like i
said the movie had the balls to pretty
much kill everybody off yeah and that
killed him off like the crush girl like
the girl the pizza guy had the crush on
what's her name i can't remember i don't
remember um i'd have to see it again
jessie jesse that was her name and uh i
mean she got killed and it was kind of
like i liked that they didn't make a big
deal out of it it was just like boop
she's dead and the and the guy that
liked her was just kind of like what the
you know what i mean the civilian every
every character in this movie is in a
different movie basically the civilian
characters are basically in the movie
the blob yeah very much that story
the military characters are very much in
alien 2.
uh the predator is in his own movie
fighting the
fighting the aliens you know so it's
kind of like a bunch of movies mashed
together but it all works because each
each group of characters is in their own
situation
it's very different yeah humans would be
in a very different way yeah you really
do get the sense that these are just
humans that are having like a normal day
and then all of a sudden they're just
like caught in the middle of something
that really doesn't have anything to do
with them right which is that's the blob
right steve mcqueen now meter right hits
he's trying to hey man we're under
attack now they're not you know then
eventually the townspeople in the army
can the fire department shows up to try
to stop the blob it's a lot like the
blob that part yeah
and then then people try to get let's we
got to get to the helicopter
get to the choppa
but i think that's why it's good that
they weren't shy about killing off most
of the people most of the characters
because
yeah like the kids and stuff because
that's what would happen because like i
said the aliens the predators the
predalien they're just they're doing
their [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] about
the humans y'all are just in the way
your obstacles if you get killed it
doesn't matter and so i like that's that
bleakness that sense of you know they're
we're just getting stomped on
it you know we got involved in it and it
doesn't even have anything to do with us
we're just like in the caught in the
crossfire and his son getting the face
huggers on him that's just another
version of the damn bum in the woods
that got the blob on his hand it's that
same yeah some fell from the sky and it
got him yeah somebody was talking about
the acid like making the dad's arm fall
off and i was like yeah i really i liked
that and that happens like pretty early
in the movie and i'm like all right yeah
and then the kids little kids seeing it
got pow and then the thing comes out of
the kids and i was like all right then
he wakes up hey dad yeah i killed that
kid no
i'm just well you know a lot of horror
movies aren't ballsy enough to like kill
the kid off they always get rescued at
the last minute or some lame [ __ ] like
that i like it better than ap avp1 i did
as well um i did it as well like i said
avp1 you could see it clearly it was
still a good movie yeah but the casting
decisions of avp1 are kind of very
corporate and cartoonish and not real i
found this one more engaging like the
characters are more engaging
because the first one was okay but i
kind of found myself like spacing out
every now and then because i thought it
was kind of boring yeah um and this one
even though i kind of feel like this one
has less fight scenes or less action
particularly in the first act because
the first act is pretty much
establishing all these characters like
their interrelated relationships and
stuff um but that didn't even like seem
boring to me i was just kind of like all
right whatever like they all seemed okay
characters and uh you know so then once
the monster action starts you know then
it starts getting really good but yeah i
didn't
i don't know i i
i didn't really get how hated this movie
wasn't like universally hated because
even some critics at the time said nah
that was pretty good you know it has
mostly five stars now
yeah well i saw on google reviews uh i
think it was 77 percent positive okay um
so i think some people because it's
[ __ ] almost five stars
i think it's 4.8 stars yeah so i mean i
guess it depends because then on the
rotten tomatoes i think it's 12 but the
first one is 12 too so i don't believe
rotten tomatoes well that's what i mean
but i'm just saying that it's kind of
all over the map
uh i did watch i did see a lot of um you
know youtubers like horror youtubers and
stuff that reviewed it and a lot of them
really didn't like it
um but
and i can kind of see that but honestly
it's really not it's not that bad yeah i
thought it was like pretty good like i
said they just lightened it up and you
know loosened up the edit a little bit
in the fight scenes i think it would
have been like a perfectly acceptable
movie yeah i did i thought it was just
i still think it's kind of a strong
entry it's one of the better alien
predator movies it's not perfect it's a
little it's too dark
that's actually fixable yeah i mean
that's very easy to fix right and but
the ideas behind it and certain things
that happen real enjoyable
uh the idea of the damn game warden's
showing up it's good good lore it's
another movie you can watch i probably
would put it
in terms of enjoyability
as good i think it's as good as
predators
predators the one on the alien planet
with the the hunting planet about like
that yeah that's what they were just
talking about that one because no need
for me too said i like the adrian brody
one yeah predators i liked that as well
that was actually really good yeah and i
think as these things get older people
get more forgiving of them too you know
they
just yeah i mean well sometimes when you
see it when it came out it wasn't what
you were expecting or something like
there was some other thing but then
sometimes if you know 20 years later and
then you watch it and you're just like
oh okay well because you've forgotten
what expectations you had and blah blah
blah so then like you watch it well i
think i was talking about the same thing
because uh you know on one of my reviews
that i did the other day of jennifer's
body which came out in 2009 and i feel
like that got a lot of [ __ ] hate when
it first came out and like i watched it
and i'm just like why the [ __ ] did
everybody hate this movie back then this
is like a pretty awesome [ __ ] movie
um i don't know if people just didn't
get it back then or i don't know but you
know there's there's lots of things uh
somebody said uh the blob remake was
good honestly i've been wanting to do
that 1988 blob remake on the show
forever we need to really do that one of
these days because that movie kicks ass
khan just suggests we haven't done
pandora that's a good movie we need to
do pandora
yeah
um
let's do that tuesday because
uh we last night we didn't go out last
night but our friends angel and mike
came over
uh and hung out had a couple drinks and
some spaghetti and stuff
and i was talking to angel and she said
do you remember a movie she said when i
was a little kid you know and you used
to go
because she's the same age as me and we
used to go to the drive-in and they
would do like a triple feature or they
would do like movies all night so you
know your parents would like but it was
like really cheap so your parents would
bundle you get all your blankies and
snacks and stuff and then you'd go to
the drive-in and you would watch like
three movies and they said usually they
had like a family one and then they had
kind of like a you know a
middle-of-the-road kind of one and then
they'd usually have like a scary movie
like a horror movie because they assumed
that the kids would be asleep by then uh
so she said when she was i don't
remember how old she said she was but
she said she was pretty young they went
to the drive-in and she said i saw this
movie called slithus
and she's like and that movie scared the
absolute [ __ ] out of me and i said you
know what i said i saw a poster for that
the other day where the [ __ ] did i see
that and so i went on to be and it's on
there now i don't think i've ever seen
it but she said please do a review of
that because she's like i haven't seen
it since i was a kid and i remember it
scaring the crap out of me and it gave
me nightmares and stuff and she's like
and i'd be really interested
to see if it's as scary as i remember so
i wrote it down and i said okay we're
totally gonna do that because it's for
free on tubey it might be on amazon
prime too i'm sure but so i'm gonna
write down so i wrote down slithes and
then we'll write down pandora yeah i
actually uh would want to do pandora as
well because that was another one that's
that's been on the list like for a long
time but we just haven't got around to
it yet
that might be on um
it's not on amazon prime or maybe on
netflix or something cons asked me if i
ever played alien isolation i got um a
bit
i got it and um
i played it for like uh about a couple
week or so i probably got maybe like one
third the way through it and then just
got distracted i got to go back and
finish it it's
a lot of hiding and sneaking around
trying to get get through that ship
it's pretty good
it's all right
it looked cool like when i've seen you
playing it a couple times yeah it's hard
stealth game
yeah
all right do we have anything else we
need to talk just don't do the comments
and see catching up with what people are
saying but yeah so tomorrow we'll
probably do slithers we can watch that
tonight because i'm now i'm kind of
curious because she was like please do
that because
i want to see and then yeah i've been
wanting to do pandora anyway so maybe we
can do that one on tuesday that'll work
out okay and then uh
yeah
most people kind of are uh agreeing that
it's better than [ __ ]
the last
predator yeah i didn't mind that movie
but there you know there was a lot about
it that i don't really remember but i
mean in
that movie's defense or
not wait not really what am i saying
okay but this movie
even though i i could have sworn that i
hadn't seen it but then when we started
watching it i had seen it
so the first time i saw it which was
probably in the late 2000s
uh i didn't remember anything about it
so
it didn't make much of an impression but
like i said i'm not i love alien
uh you know the first alien i love
aliens i love the first predator
but
i'm not usually one i don't usually like
sequels so i don't usually bother
um you know because they're it's just
not as cool once you've seen it i don't
want to see more of that so i don't
usually bother with it and i'm not
usually real into like sci-fi and i
don't like i don't usually like
crossover type movies you know like
freddy versus jason i did see that but i
liked these though they're all right
yeah but yeah they're they're totally
like they're totally acceptable now uh
we're talking about the newer ones the
predator
it had a lot of problems one of the
biggest problems was the [ __ ] title
[ __ ] that title the predator
why did they keep doing that because i
kind of feel it's so confusing because
they did it recently too with the latest
scream
which is actually scream part
five or six i can't remember i think
it's part six but then they just called
it scream like the first movie from
1996. i'm like why and they did the same
thing with like the thing
yeah it's like what just call it
something else yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] it give it at least give it a
subtitle or something it's like it's you
know it's like what this is the predator
this is predators this is predator
apostrophe s you know what i mean it's
like what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah uh the predator with a semicolon at
the end the predator sucked because of
the title
uh [ __ ] wonky [ __ ] edit
with a bunch of [ __ ] comedy that
shouldn't have really been in there
it had a good idea the [ __ ] nut cases
from the va [ __ ] great idea all right
i liked that part yeah i remember that
one and some of the va guys were [ __ ]
great all right the tourette's
syndrome's guy was [ __ ] uh annoying
um
what else is wrong with it
it just kind of was boring
yeah i was just kind of boring yeah i
didn't really remember much about it the
yeah the whole idea of
let's change the predator up a bit
uh it's stealing dna from people and
breeding itself into a better form bad
idea okay then that means the predator
can be anything so it's not the predator
anymore
yeah yeah you can make it the thing now
okay he's the thing
now he's the now he can just change into
whatever he wants that's the next movie
predator is the thing
just 2025 predator thing yeah yeah yeah
it would have been better to just
[ __ ] include some more stuff
about
the predator home world and their laws
and new characters and maybe uh new
characters that are the predators don't
demystify them so much and in the end
the [ __ ] flying
suit to make you as good as a predator
dumb idea that's [ __ ] dumb
i mean
at least this movie avp requiem at least
this movie had the balls to be like if
if earth was invaded by predators aliens
predaliens humans would just be [ __ ]
there wouldn't really be anything you
could do well you know you know and i
liked that bleakness to it because it
was realistic you would be hosed there
would be nothing you could do well okay
if technology was going to be
the the the the solution it wouldn't be
a flying armored suit that'd be the last
thing you'd want what you'd want is
you'd want a a flying swarm of drones
that are like the size of a damn
[ __ ] dragonfly and they're explosive
that's unstoppable since you were
talking about like a suit i was just
talking about oh predator versus iron
man that's going to be accidental
tony stark versus the predator a real
human solution to something like the
predators or aliens would be tiny drone
swarms
totally realistic and you could maybe
write a story like that we got all these
little [ __ ] drones
and they can kick ass they can't run
from them
um
now you know they're going to try to
find a way around that emps to [ __ ]
destroy [ __ ] drones which that's fair
but there are there are some human
technologies that
probably could that realistically would
give you a chance to give you a chance
things that were sitting on the ground
drones that sit on the ground like
little land mines you don't see them
they're too small when you walk through
the downfield they jump up and explode
aim for your face and blow up like a 22
caliber [ __ ] bullet in your head you
know
which they work on they're working on
[ __ ] they have [ __ ] like that
yeah so
yeah
that would that would be a lot more
workable than tony stark
yeah i mean i get that they're trying to
do like the human angle thing but
the secret wouldn't be human angles the
secret right drones
robots you know like i said i know why
they do that it's like you know
everybody likes to have relatable human
characters because you're presumably a
human going to see the movie so
you know they're trying to do that but
there comes a point when you can't
really suspend your disbelief in that
regard anymore so technology won't go in
that direction and i mean you could
still have a human interest you could
have the guy that invented that yeah the
guys they're running the drones right
that are kind of like you know deploying
it then yeah you could like have a human
story there sure because he's the weak
link in the system right
jason versus the predator
not gonna lie i'd probably watch that
i'd have to i'd get drunk and watch it
yeah i mean
that well you know what that might
actually be like an interesting mashup
because yeah i mean when you just think
about it for a second you think well
obviously the predator would would kick
jason's ass but jason is like a
supernatural demon you just keep coming
back and he would just keep coming back
like you could [ __ ] cut him into
pieces and put him in a wood chipper and
he just like reassembles like a t2 you
know what i mean there's some [ __ ] that
could be used that just hasn't been used
like they they tried to revive the
shadow remember that it was about 20
something years ago maybe now that was a
long time ago a long time ago in the 90s
that was the 90s 90s and that movie
looked great but it just had a shitty
villain
dumb
uh they could have actually done
something along the lines of batman with
the shadow because that was a cool
character
but you have to have a [ __ ] badass
villain for a movie i mean yeah for
pretty much any kind of any kind of
movie really but specifically and horror
and sci-fi and stuff like that is really
only as strong as your villain
uh you know i wouldn't mind
if i had money and wanted to do
something in the [ __ ] superhero world
bring back bring back the shadow but you
do it right
i kind of feel like it's sort of like
the the time is right for that because i
feel like when they did it i know i
when was that 97 i can't remember but um
i kind of feel like when they did that
that was prior to
um you know there being this big thing
in like superhero type movies or movies
of that type i kind of feel like if you
made it nowadays i think people would be
a lot more receptive to it i don't
really know there wasn't much of an
audience for that type of movie back
then and that's a great super power the
uh the ultimate superpower dude could
cloud the human mind he was a psychic it
could cloud minds get you to see things
that weren't there you'd get you
couldn't see him
or you thought you couldn't see him
but it was just it was mind control
yeah i mean yeah i would like to see
because [ __ ] man that that goes back to
like the [ __ ] early radio serials
does it not yeah i think that's where
that came from yeah i forgot i don't
remember i don't think he could read
minds
or he could hear your thoughts i don't
know oh yeah he was rare yeah it was
kind of like batman
he had 45s
pretty good fourth jordan said there's a
short animated film on youtube called
batman vs the terminator it sounds lame
but it's actually really good is it
huh batman vs terminator yeah it's it's
a bootleg no it's animated it's animated
i mean i'm guessing i don't know if
anybody like legitimately
legally made that but
i mean you can make fan [ __ ] like that
all day long because you don't like char
as long as you don't charge money for it
yeah you can put it up for free on
youtube if you want to yeah khan also
brings up spawn about time to have spawn
come back too
because yeah movie was pretty good yeah
uh they
they didn't really
i think it came out a little too early
they never really worked with it
they should have done yeah i kind of a
lot of movies that came out because
kanavatsan has just brought up dark man
and i was like yeah that's actually like
a really good concept also that i think
would probably work better and people
would be more receptive to it nowadays
than they were but
make that awesome now yeah
yeah i mean i think that would be really
good also dark city
yeah yeah i never saw it oh i like that
movie a lot we thought we should review
that at some point you probably like it
in a way dark man was kind of like the
shadow kind of kind of yeah which is
probably why he thought of it but you
but either one would work
yeah
i'm surprised i haven't got around to
doing it because like i said i just kind
of feel like it's more
see with the shadow i would go film noir
that's what i was gonna say i think that
would be really awesome yeah he was kind
of like a detective private detective
kind of like batman but he was a psychic
and you saw him in ways that he didn't
appear but he could make you think that
he looked that way
it wouldn't work in today's uh
environment
because
i don't think he could fool the video
camera
you'd have to get away it was only the
human mind yeah i wonder they'd have to
like come up with some sort of
work around for that or maybe that's
like his weakness that's his weakness
things that but yeah that might be good
actually right that's we're writing the
whole movie in our head like right now
that might be in public domain now i
don't know how old that property is well
no because i mean i'm assuming since
they made a movie of in the 90s i'm
assuming that somebody owns that
property because
things only go into the public domain
i think uh you know if what is it it's
life of the author plus 100 years and
then
but if they have like a family that has
still like maintained the rights or you
know a company that's maintained the
rights over time then you know then you
still need permission to use it there's
a con man there's some mexican ones that
were never done right man zorro was
never done right you could they could
have done a really good
zorro during the day the last zoro they
did had antonio banderas yeah that was
close it was all right it was close but
you could have done a they could have
done a really good zorro during mexican
revolution times
they had another um
uh marvel villain who was a a mexican
character i believe he was mexican
remember his name was the tarantula
he was fighting [ __ ] spider-man a lot
he was he was he kind of had spider-man
type
abilities
uh remember he had these damn shoes big
old spikes on the end of it remember
that [ __ ] kind of kind of like
daredevil
he had a black bandana tied around his
head with [ __ ] eye slits in it
i think yeah
red outfit with a [ __ ] red red red
outfit with a black tarantula on it
you could they could do something with
that
he was a spider-man villain
yeah i'm surprised they haven't uh they
haven't used him in anything because
they're mexican spiders they've made
like 40 million spider-man movies right
roughly
so uh dating rolling ghost faces dark
city easily overpowers all the matrix
films i agree i actually liked dark city
much better even than the first matrix
and it's honestly it's kind of the same
well i don't know if i want to say it's
the same concept it's similar but
much weirder yeah uh but and it's also
done like a noir yeah which was probably
what i really liked about it
but um yeah you should see it you'd
probably really like it i really like it
yeah conor says zorro could be badass
yeah and he remembers the tarantula he
said he forgot about him yeah you could
make a damn
something kind of like the punisher out
of the trash of the like a
anti he was kind of like an
anti-spider-man
that would have been good
well as i said they just keep making
spider-man movies i'm sure they'll get
around to him
i don't even remember i remember like
some of the some of the artwork like
from some of the old spider-man comments
red
his red outfit with a bunch of black on
it black boots had he had i think he had
a spike on the front of his boots it was
about six inches long on both of them i
think they might have been poisonous if
i remember correctly i mean that would
make sense because it was kind of like
yeah
and stuff right like fangs like it's
been fun he had like a
a mask tied around and it was tied in
the back almost kind of like not quite a
zoro mask i guess but like
i don't know just almost like some gypsy
would wear or something but you could
change all that you know they changed
looks all the time you know i mean
that was 70s marvel and nothing from the
70s survives on the big screen they've
changed everything just basic colors
that's it
but
iron man kinda looked like that but iron
man looked like a lot of stuff over the
years yeah because most of those
characters have been around for such a
long time that they and they had
different artists working on them and
[ __ ] like that too so
it was basically nude forms covered
just drawn in a way to make it look like
it had tights on yeah you know and that
does
the old superman was like that with the
chris reeves basically that but you just
can't do that anymore it doesn't look
good
the the costumes that they have now it
has to the the costume has to have some
kind of substance to it yeah yeah it has
to look cool it has to look a lot cooler
than that you can't just look like
you're walking around wearing your
wife's pantyhose yeah
and they were that only looked good in
drawings it doesn't it doesn't look good
in photographs or
chris reeves was the only guy who really
and he pulled it off and he only kind of
pulled it off
it doesn't look very good
well it is kind of like a silly outfit
it's like it's comfortable i could move
around did it what do you want from me
look like [ __ ] pajamas
all right yeah
all right yeah we're just man we've been
going on almost an hour yeah uh but yeah
so three-hour show yeah
well you know that's what happens yeah
uh yeah so have a good rest of your
weekend you guys will be back again
tomorrow afternoon talking about slithes
probably or
pandorum whichever one we feel like
watching tonight but we'll do those two
over the next couple days because i
don't want to do pandora for a long time
anyway so uh yeah have a good rest to
your sunday thanks for dropping by
thanks for super chats and we will see
you guys again tomorrow afternoon
bye